hi there steve here steve kaufman today
i want to talk about the first steps in
a new language for me it's greek
it's all greek to me
uh if you like these videos by the way
please subscribe
um so as i said the other day i've
decided to start learning greek
and one of the things that i did was to
buy this living language uh set
and i've been using this essential which
is the beginning
first book in the series
but mostly i've been studying our link
because i have found the um
the living language book not to be that
useful
um i'll explain why
lots of sort of just give you a bunch of
words and very early on they introduce
exercises
which i don't like i mean very early in
chapter two here they're teaching you
the words for grandmother grandfather
nephew cousin
mother-in-law i've never understood why
in language books they introduce to you
the names of all potential members of
your family
colors and all kinds of things that are
relatively
useless when you start out in a language
and the grammar is introduced in in sort
of small drips and drabs so i haven't
been actually using it very much instead
i have been using link here on my ipad
and basically what i do here is uh here
we are
i read through the first we have a thing
called who is she which is a one of our
beginner
stories it's 26
chapters in a story that's actually a
story that progresses
each story or each chapter is about a
minute long
and i know the story because we have the
same story in all of the languages that
link
so and i have i should begin by saying i
have two goals when i start in a new
language like greek which is completely
new to me
with no vocabulary or very little common
vocabulary with any language that i know
uh two things that i want to achieve
right up front one i want to get to the
point where i can hear the words so that
i could this can distinguish where a
word ends and a new word begins i gotta
hear those sounds because when you first
start is just noise and the second thing
i have to do is get used to the writing
system and for me getting used to the
writing system means being able to read
because listening and reading are key to
my way of learning
so in order to do that i've decided i'm
going to go through the 26 chapters
lessons in who is she and i do them in
groups of five
so
i've now been doing the first five and i
i do them on my ipad and then i listen
i've created a playlist
in the uh iphone app i by the way on the
i on the
ipad i'm also using the mobile app
for link
but my iphone is now being used to film
this so i can't show you my playlist but
i listen to these five stories over and
over and over again i don't understand a
thing i mean i pick up the odd word it's
a bit like a jigsaw puzzle as you are
able to grab more and more words they
get more of a sense of what it's all
about
but in order to get to where i can
understand at least some of these five
stories when i listen to them
i have to go through them here on the
ipad which you can't see very well but
i save individual words and i say
phrases so you can probably hear this
that's the individual word we are
looking
and someone
capion
so i go through and as i go through it
in this way
i can
make sense because of course the meaning
i have the meaning here
and i start to recognize
sort of how certain words are no these
are obviously verbs there's a pronoun in
there there's all kinds of stuff so as i
go through it
i'm achieving a number of things i'm
getting a sense of the sounds i'm
getting a bit of a sense of the meaning
although when i go out i go off and
listen without having the text in front
of me i don't understand much
i'm also getting a sense of of what i
want to know in terms of grammar so for
example i want to know
how these how the verbs conjugate in
greek i get the sense
you plural so i get some of a sense of
that so then
again rather than looking through my
living language to find that i found it
more convenient to simply google greek
verbs or
greek pronouns
and later on i might google for greek
adjectives in doing that i found some
very good websites for greek grammar but
again i don't want to read the whole
grammar
i just want to
you know look at those things that are
of interest to me there are some strange
things in greek the way they use the
articles again article just google greek
articles so then i can get the specific
grammar issues that are making it a
little bit
difficult for me to
follow how the words are put together
but the main activity
is still
listening and reading so i'm not yet at
the point where i can
uh listen and understand
i'm getting much better at reading
because i am
either
reading and then you know listening to
the text to speech for the words and
phrases that i have saved on link and
then following that along
let's uh step back a bit with regard to
the greek alphabet or any new alphabet
of course initially you you you look at
the individual
uh you know sounds of the symbols
which the greek alphabet is not that
difficult compared to let's say i'm sure
arabic will be much more difficult
but uh you don't get it right away uh
but you start to get a toehold on it and
then certain letters continue to give
you trouble and you look those up again
and
but but eventually you have to get to
where you're reading and and gradually
starting to um basically connect the
sounds of words
uh with the letters that are used to to
write those words uh so i'm getting
there so i figure
within another um couple of weeks i
should be able to be at the point where
i actually understand some of what i'm
listening to and it's becoming easier
and easier to read
i am going to even though i don't
understand much of what i listen to when
i'm just listening
uh
i'm just motivated to go on and do
another five lessons so i will continue
listening to the first five lessons i
will work my way through the second five
lessons looking up words and phrases
which again is helping me hear the
language helping me read with the
alphabet and now i'll have 10 lessons
that i don't understand and then i'll go
back and listen to them again and so
there'll be a gradual process there
which i think
based on my experience within a month or
so
i will be able to understand quite a bit
and along the way
any grammar issues that come up
verbs nouns
pronouns adjectives
other things i will look them up using
google
and then if i want more of an overview
of greek grammar there's lots of
websites and and but the point is i have
to have had some experience with
different issues in the language before
these explanations relate to anything
that makes sense to me so there you have
it that's just a brief description of my
first steps i don't know where i put my
little remote control guy
uh
first steps in greek
and we'll see how things go and thank
you for oh i want to add one more thing
i did try duolingo and i'm gonna go back
there but duolingo i ran into an
immediate roadblock is that no matter
what you do
um they very quickly ask you to write
something
in greek to translate from english to
greek and since i don't want to start
doing that
because i don't want to start using the
greek alphabet to write yet i want to
more passively absorb the language so
i've held off
on duolingo until i'm a little further
ahead in the language but when i do that
i'll do a little
report on duolingo and my experience
there okay bye-bye
[Music]
you